ora my friends siamo su un maio lisa j
non ho scelto questo gioco per il titolo
non so se si è capito è un rpg horror
quindi di quei giochi che io ho sempre
fatto e da un botto di tempo non ne vedo
uno nuovo
secondo me potrebbe essere si è fatto
bene al di là del titolo e del font che
hanno dato politico che potrebbe essere
una figata che partenza è c'è una mano
con una croce è ok
[Musica]
io non so niente di quello che siamo
i ragazzi però è fatto tipo mani ecco
molto più come yves il mio nome e mol è
stato dato come discepolo del signore
per la madonna
ma cosa sono santo iddio sembra mia zia
va bene questo è il buco dove devo
scendere per recarmi nuova casa sono già
pronto a lasciare tutte le speranze di
discendi e se questo è il suo volere che
lo sia
in realtà questa sfera lasciatemi stanza
perché entrate si entra all inferno però
fa niente affatto grazie poteva avere la
voce un po più tipo il gabibbo tipo le
pa pe ro generico assumere nella
cappella e molto bene a bruciare una
saga non bastava e basta pensarci due
volte
cosa l'importante blocco di dire questa
cosa importante è cosa mai detto è un
ambulanza che succede una cosa sta
succedendo signore mio come comunque la
non mi posso immaginare dio con la voce
del gabibbo
sono stato molto bene la natura natura
di tutto ma non prevenuto il promo ad
uso possono fare tutto quel che c'è
gente nell'oscurità una donna il
confronto era per bambini poi mi si
muove anche l'ombra che tristezza che
cosa veramente macabra vado da sotto c'è
una scala scendi scendi scendi per forza
che devo faccendi dove stiamo andando
ragazzi dove sta
dov'è che dio mi sta portando ho scavato
io tutto sto bordello vaghe casinò ho
fatto tutto perché devono creare un
posto sicuro una cappella sono pagato
nelle mutande c'è un tizio con un collo
lunghissimo sono morto acqua era un
sogno ok
ultimamente ho iniziato a sentire la sua
voce di più e di più nel mentre che ero
sveglio è un segno della fine del mondo
che sta avvicinando
sempre di più qualsiasi sia la causa
devo comunque eseguire il mio sermone
giornaliero andiamo al mio sermone
consista musica bellissimo c'è la croce
qua e sfruttare un'altra che sono tutta
un'altra no disputare un miliardo questa
canzone
e vabbè cosa sto gioca a cosa sto
giocando a cosa sto giocando o bel
sermone comunque è veramente il giorno
inquieta da morire sta roba non sono la
sua giocando kyosanto kit gruppo era
quello che prima fosse gusto spotify c'è
una scala lì però prima entrerò nella
porta a mascara lingua italiano della
scarpa che chiamano mi rappresenta
proprio direttamente alla porta non mi
perdo che va dalla porta invece ama
quindi la città e sinistra e il mio
posto preferito in tutto il pool le luci
della città sono solo distanti e così
ecco eppure sono così calde il comando
di via così bello ma è anche così terry
ma tu cane e ceo ti riconosco
aspetta aspetta lì arrivo ecco arrivo è
il mio cane quello che devo fare tutto
il giro che è rottura di tual quindi
ragazzi in tutto sto casino il mondo non
è finito
eccomi è intorno a qua sono io molti
ricordi di me dove stai andando torna
indietro per favore è successo immagino
che tu non voglio guardarmi più va bene
non ti biasimo londra
il tempo è arrivato devi prendere real
che andiamo andiamo andiamo sì signore
dio mio è già troppo tardi per me che se
sta arrivando l'apocalisse in questo
istante tutto il mondo sta per finire in
questo preciso momento
in tutto il casino che ho fatto tutte le
costruzioni sotto terra che ho fatto che
dio mi ha detto di fare si avvereranno
in questo momento proprio perché io
rispetto a tutti gli altri sono fatti i
cazzi loro
invece mi sono impegnato per costruire
questo fottutissimo tunnel sotterraneo e
adesso andiamo nel rifugio che sta nella
cappella cosa la porta sono arrivato
sono salvo al mio rifugio devo prendere
un momento per riposarmi riordina di
pensiero come non c'è tempo per quello
morgan devi andare più in fondo sotto
terra e trovare le parole
sì però puoi dirlo anche senza ruttare
tutto questo è trovare la mia culla
credo o dire culla troviamo la culla di
dio la culla culla di dio che cos'è non
lo so ha detto niente però poi c'è un
cesso un cesso qui installato in caso di
emergenza chissà dove porta lo scarico è
quindi porca put vacca che è successo
siamo in un posto molto allegro ho
capito ma in tutto questo noi questo a
questa parte l'ho fatta io o no l'ho
fatta io scendere
profondità scegli profondità questa è
tutta una roba che ha fatto dio cioè non
ho scavato così in basso credo ce l'ho
messo io sti birilli ora messi dio dio
ci hai messo tutti birilli questa
diavolo estra musica ma poi soprattutto
perché ho fatto un passaggio che sembra
un labirinto del problema che palle fai
le strade dritte
siamo in una miniera una miniera di scò
ilsa discoteca dio ho trovato una
trovata culla protata discoteca a disco
music
ma metti un po un pezzaccio tipo quella
dell'ecofin dance non c'è un occhio
tutto a posto ragazzi di profumati
quarta faq devo consegnare il bambino
che potter o signore che cos'è questa
creatura come posso consegnare questa
cosa io dammi una risposta non lasciarmi
solo invece mai lasciato solo prendiamo
il bambino che si dimena come se fosse
un muppet entrando nel buco per
consegnare piccolo marshmallow che il
bambino mio è dato un nome porco il
demonio se mio figlio non lo chiama
marshmallow guarda è l'iter marshmallow
live to find you up emily dove tua mamma
evita il marshmallow è morto però visto
che c'è stata l'apocalisse c'è
un'altissima probabilità gavedo ok sto
passando orco il demonio chicca singer e
questo da ragazzi
o c'è un bambino qua volete farlo
spaventare a morte appena nato che già
un casino dio mi ha detto che devo
consegnarlo solo che non ci stanno i
corrieri di amazon perché giustamente
l'apocalisse quindi devo consegnare io
le cose tipo index trending il triplo
tutti guarda dio che giocatore della
madonna che c'è nel senso sono un bravo
giocatore bravo bravo proprio bravo
ecco qua sentiti o edotto consegnato sto
frugolo c'è stata disco rossa c'è una
croce che si muove vade retro demonio
cos'è sta cosa dio hai un senso
dell'arredamento veramente strano se
devo fossoli però vabbè che famo questa
culla no tra cullando nella collettiva
la cultura una gigante bocca simone
anigas e l'under simon chi sono io non è
importante cosa importante che il tuo
dio ti ha mentito che vedete questo è
stata mai semplicemente mi sta dicendo
che dio mi ha mentito è che io una viola
col ma chi paga chi sorridendo raga ma
che cacchio sto vedendo non ho capito
cosa sta succedendo
ma sono quasi un qualche ok può fare
qualcosa prima
affittiamo sul divano a prendi un pezzo
di vetro e taglia chi ha ammazzato me
stesso il bambino li di via attraverso
di me l'inter marshmallow i miei inside
sono tuoi
io sarò lì dentro di testa
però consegniamo all'international ok lo
ferito l'ho aperto
va bene spacchiamo tutto e allora o
sacrosanto gesù sta diventando tutto
molto molto infernale prova niente
una donna che pur i pip non spostare ste
robe ce l'ho fatta c'è un tipo che mi
segue madonne orribile è veramente una
cosa più brutta abbia visto sembra
milizia con la parrucca via via via via
via via via con ci posso passare con ci
passano sarà invece si era giocato poco
e non sa come la mia vita non usare
forza anche spacca roccia volendo no al
piano dei grossi di nuovo aiuto né odio
ste cose perché non riesco a districarmi
unipol e pure c'è pure satana ci mancava
quello ricava e come passo non c'e passo
non c'è passo non ci passo non ci fa non
ci posso passare non ci potremo
boh io non dormirò mai più 12 non mi
fate mai più consegnare bambini 3 meno
male che faccio youtuber perché
consegnare per amazon sarebbe stato un
problema
probabile vi sia piaciuto ragazzi questa
maglia o esami del cielo del prossimo
programma
[Musica]